I said Tim last week I was like when do
I get invited on Matt Damon vacation
will say wait note to Chris Hemsworth
your men in black International co-star
Tessa Thompson once an invite to your
new mega mansion in Australia I'm
petitioning to have a room in this home
because he is an animal lover so they
have three donkeys which I've met no two
donkeys three horses three guinea pigs
two rabbits some sort of scaly thing I
don't know what it is you know Australia
has weird animals they have all sorts of
animals so I'm like just if you need
like a house sitter for all these
animals I'm available anytime but I've
been to his old home and Brian brain is
beautiful the hit him and else are the
best hosts in the new MIB flick Tessa
and Chris play agents who team up and
travel the globe together catching up on
my daily meditation time for lunch ah
thank you hungry it's 9:30 Tuesday's
taco day and turns out things aren't so
different in real life the actors have
been busy going to different countries
promoting the new film
he's pretty low-key I mean his entourage
is the sweetest thing ever because it
consists of his parents and like his
childhood friend who helps him out and
the you know Luca and Matteo who do his
hair and makeup for everything for all
the Thor movies everything he's ever
done so it feels real family homegrown
and he and I just enjoy eating a lot
together
honestly that's like basically what we
did the whole tour won all kinds of food
we
I mean it's so fancy it's like you feel
like it's like Cinderella
you know someone at one point you just
feel like someone's gonna tap you on the
shoulder and say you're not supposed to
be here but so until they do we ate
caviar and we were in China's weight
lots of local cuisine there it was
really a beautiful tour
and come on being the style queen that
she is we knew Tessa was gonna deliver a
major fashion moment on her big night it
is a work of art it's by Rodarte and
they've become good friends of mine and
they made this dress from scratch just
for me for tonight and I feel so lucky
because they it's just you know fashion
is whatever but it's the it's the work
of real artisans it's that you know it's
a lot of blood sweat and tears so I'm so
grateful to wear this dress today the
ruffle situation is like butt ruching I
don't even know it's handy because if
you get shy at the after party you're
just like I can do that
thank you yes it's beautiful right it's
a Judith Leiber and it's a moon and it's
special to me obviously because this
movie is about the cosmos but also in my
family the way we say I love you is to
the moon and I have my whole family here
tonight so it's special
[Music]